[Música]
y
escocia despide a la reina isabel
segunda su féretro está en la catedral
de saint gilles después de ser
trasladado desde hollywood house además
está en capilla ardiente durante 24
horas antes de ser llevado a londres el
nuevo monarca del rey carlos tercero se
reunió con el parlamento de cosas
eeuu invita a méxico a producir
semiconductores así lo expresaron el
secretario de estado de eeuu al tony
blinken y la secretaria de comercio gina
raimondo tras reunirse con el presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador los
detalles en minutos desde la capital
mexicana
en suecia podría haber un gobierno de
derecha después de 8 años del partido
socialdemócratas en el poder los
resultados provisionales de las
elecciones generales del domingo
posicionan por primera vez en la
historia a la extrema derecha de los
demócratas de suecia como el segundo
partido más votado
bienvenidos a las noticias
internacionales de france 24 yo soy
maría clara calle comenzamos en escocia
decenas de personas continúan rindiendo
su último adiós a la reina isabel
segunda el ataúd de la monarca estará en
la iglesia de sant james hasta el martes
y luego lo llevarán vía aérea desde
edimburgo hasta londres y es que antes
de llegar a la catedral estaba en el
palacio real escocés de la monarquía
manuel acá no nos cuenta
el recorrido comenzó en el palacio
hollywood house
el rey carlos tercero encabezó la
posesión del ataúd de la reina isabel
por las calles de edimburgo en escocia
acompañado por la reina consorte camila
y miembros de la familia real como la
princesa ana y los príncipes and you
edwards el cuerpo de la reina llegó a su
primera parada la catedral de saint
georges el camino estuvo marcado por la
solemnidad y la emoción de los
espectadores al lado y lado de la
carretera
tengo 47 años toda mi vida escuché sobre
esta increíble mujer no soy de aquí soy
de muy lejos pero para mí no es sólo tu
reina es mi reina también
amo a la reina como siempre lo he hecho
estaba muy molesta cuando murió me
enteré en la escuela y muchas personas
de mi edad realmente no aprecian lo
mucho que ha hecho y lo duro que ha
trabajado
en medio de la emoción el ataúd fue
ingresado en la catedral allí
permanecerá durante 24 horas antes de
seguir su peregrinación hasta londres la
familia real la primera ministra de
escocia nicola sturgeon y la primera
ministra británica listos entre otros
presenciaron una ceremonia íntima y
suntuosa en la que el negro de los
vestidos de los asistentes contrastó con
las luces del lugar y donde se entonó el
himno nacional
[Música]
el acto también estuvo lleno de
simbolismo como la corona de escocia
colocada sobre el ataúd de la reina a
las afueras el ambiente es diferente las
largas filas de los seguidores de la
monarca marcan el panorama de edimburgo
en estas deberán esperar varias horas
para poder entrar a la catedral allí se
espera que miles de personas desfilen
para darle un último adiós a la monarca
en noticias de la guerra del presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski afirmó que
sus tropas han recuperado 6 mil
kilómetros cuadrados que antes estaban
en poder de moscú la contraofensiva
comenzó el 6 de septiembre y con ella
ucrania ha tomado el poder en lugares de
la región dejar keith en el norte y de
gerson en el sur este repentino avance
de kiev podría representar un punto de
inflexión en el conflicto después de
meses de estancamiento y también le está
trayendo problemas al mandatario ruso
vladimir putin en su política interna
impensable hace unos meses la bandera
ucraniana ondea en los edificios
gubernamentales de la región de jarquín
aquí el sorprendente avance ucraniano ha
hecho retroceder a las fuerzas rusas
empujando las hacia la frontera un gran
retroceso para vladimir putin quien
desde el inicio en la invasión en
febrero ha prometido una victoria rápida
lo que ha provocado algo raramente visto
en rusia una crítica de la opinión
pública hacia la figura de putin como
esta carta escrita por funcionarios
locales en moscú pidiendo al líder ruso
que renuncie estimado vladímir
vladímirovich la retórica que emplean
sus subordinados está teñida de
intolerancia y agresión desde hace mucho
tiempo y ha sumido a nuestro país en
otra era de guerra fría rusia vuelve a
ser temida y odiada le pedimos que
renuncia a su cargo porque sus opiniones
son extremadamente anticuadas y
obstaculizan el desarrollo de rusia
en san petersburgo políticos locales han
ido más allá invocando el artículo 93 de
la constitución que otorga el parlamento
el poder de destituir al jefe de estado
en caso de traición
el consejo del distrito municipal de
small niscayah decidió pedir a los
legisladores de la duma estatal que
presenten acusaciones de traición contra
el presidente putin para destituirlo de
su cargo
los autores del tuit fueron convocados
apresuradamente por la policía pero
analistas dicen que la solicitud
policial no tiene futuro putin respondió
a las críticas con hechos más que con
palabras bombardeando una central
eléctrica en la región de jarquín
causando apagones en algunas zonas
los rusos van a tratar de golpear puntos
fuertes y centrales porque el invierno
está cerca por lo que el flujo
electricidad será uno de los blancos
el kremlin dice que no habrá marcha
atrás insistiendo que la operación
militar continuará hasta que todos los
objetivos iniciales se cumplan
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador y su canciller marcelo
ebrard recibieron al secretario de
estado de eeuu anthony blinken y a la
secretaria de comercio china raimondo la
conversación estuvo centrada en los
semiconductores
eeuu e invitó al gobierno mexicano a
unirse al plan de la casa blanca de
fabricar estos chips en américa sin
tener que importarlos desde taiwán
además conversaron sobre la posibilidad
de que el 50 por ciento de los autos que
se construyan de aquí a 2030 sean
eléctricos desde la capital mexicana
nuestro corresponsal mario carbonell nos
contó más de lo que ocurrió en la
reunión
bueno el canciller marcelo ebrard dijo
que es una oportunidad histórica que es
de esas oportunidades que se dan una vez
en la vida y por lo mismo méxico acepta
con mucho entusiasmo y gratitud porque
porque esto va a implicar la generación
de miles de empleos y esto va también a
generar que la economía de méxico crezca
probablemente al doble de lo que está
creciendo actualmente con esta
invitación a participar en la
elaboración de semiconductores que hay
que decirlo no nada más en la producción
sino también en la parte de ensamblaje
de pruebas técnicas de empaquetamiento
dijo ebrard que también esto va a
contribuir a que se reduzca de manera
más pronta la pobreza en la secretaría
de economía tatiana clouthier también
señaló que méxico tiene un plan el plan
sonora para explotar el litio y que el
presidente lópez obrador lo compartió
con los funcionarios estadounidenses y
que tiene también que ver con
precisamente toda esta cadena de
suministro desde la extracción del litio
hasta la elaboración de stem y
conductores de manera tal que bueno este
fue el acuerdo principal
en materia económica también se perfiló
el próximo encuentro en materia de
seguridad para el mes de octubre y se
habló también del encuentro de líderes
de américa del norte a celebrarse en
diciembre la extrema derecha está a un
paso de ser parte del gobierno en suecia
tras los resultados provisionales de las
legislativas del domingo es que el
partido de los demócratas de suecia ha
tomado fuerza dentro de las votaciones
con la idea que defienden muchos suecos
de que la izquierda no ha cumplido los
objetivos que se ha trazado el informe
es de juan pabló lucumí
tras ocho años al mando el momento de la
izquierda podría llegar a su fin los
partidos de derecha y extrema derecha
llevan la delantera por un estrecho
margen tras las elecciones legislativas
sin embargo los socialdemócratas de la
primera ministra magdalena anderson aún
no conceden la derrota pues queda un 5%
de los distritos electorales por contar
los partidos de derecha controlarían 175
de los 349 escaños en el parlamento
apenas uno más que el bloque de
izquierda pero para algunos la tendencia
es clara
creo que es una declaración de que los
suecos quieren un cambio definitivamente
sólo es impactante porque creo que para
muchos suecos es difícil entender que
estaríamos dando un giro tan obvio hacia
la derecha hacia la extrema derecha
el sentimiento anti-inmigrante en el
país y los constantes episodios de
violencia en los suburbios entre bandas
criminales han debilitado la popularidad
del partido gobernante suecia cuenta con
una sociedad acostumbrada a tener varias
protecciones sociales desde que nacen
hasta que mueren el resto y después
todos los suecos son básicamente
socialdemócratas donde queremos un
estado fuerte queremos un bienestar
fuerte queremos un buen sistema escolar
financiado con fondos públicos entonces
los votantes demócratas suecos no son de
derecha en ese sentido pero los suecos
tienen miedo del desarrollo negativo del
mundo y de suecia
según la ley sueca el partido que
obtiene la mayor cantidad de escaños
forma el próximo gobierno el más
opcionado para convertirse en el próximo
primer ministro es el moderado wolf
christer son pero de confirmarse los
resultados el bloque de extrema derecha
que cuenta con supremacistas blancos
entre sus fundadores quedaría con gran
poder en la toma de decisiones la
inflación más alta en tres décadas y la
crisis energética que azota a varios
países de europa también se tomaron la
agenda
lo que posiblemente no cambiará a pesar
de que cambie el gobierno es la adhesión
del país a la otan con la invasión rusa
aún como telón de fondo así llegamos al
final de las noticias pero ustedes sigan
conectados con nosotros
[Música]